people talk often about um how americans
aren't really in poverty right it's like
we'll compare them to you know people in
liberia they're not in poverty but i
think the threat americans face if they
are impoverished is so intense right
it's not like to go back to the
community thing right you don't have a
lot of people to lean on you're kind of
on your own we don't have really a
social safety net at all um so you can
fall so far so and usually in debt like
you only have like a month you know to
not have that play out and you're just
trying to make it ends meet all the time
so much of our society is in that mind
frame and i don't think we properly
attribute
um that reality to some of the outcomes
that we're seeing if you falter in
america today it's very isolating
there's a lot of shame associated with
it
and you don't have that
lattice or web of connections that are
going to protect you or
put you back on your feet one of the
facts that i found striking
is that unemployed men
volunteer less and attend religious
services less than employed men right
which you think for a second is like
wait a minute you have more time so you
could clearly do those things
but when you lose that that
sense of connection and purpose you
actually withdraw
and check out what we're seeing over and
over again in american life it's it's
it's heartbreaking really when i think
about so many people whose
potential is being lost as a result
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to the
podcast someone i've been after
to have this conversation with for
months now but he's a hard man to get a
hold of
xander schultz xander welcome what's
going on brother how are you doing so
for those who are watching the video
you're like where the hell are they
right now so i'm going to ask you xander
where are we right now secret location
to be fair it's a secret location
somewhere in gotham uh mike novogratz
family office i'm the entrepreneur and
resident
at mike's family office working on
creating things that drive system change
that sounds very confusing man yeah boil
that [ __ ] down yeah yeah
i mean
i think it's important to boil down but
i also think it's like important to
announce like your mission because
sometimes like the what can be confusing
to people you know the tactical and
strategy level and then sometimes you
know if you don't announce your you know
why why why are you doing all this um
personally i have a mission of
eradicating desperation this is why i
became such a champion of you and basic
income and the momentum you had uh in
the presidential election continue to
have in all your work
and um
and then like tactically what does that
look like right now the majority of the
stuff we're launching
is focused on moving as much political
power as possible to marginalized
communities marginalized populations uh
so they can defend themselves
essentially right they can use our
political system to build that floor
that we don't have in this country and
so that's been the last
uh couple years and kind of the more
pragmatic stuff that we're doing
you and i met on the presidential and
you were one of the earliest champions
of ubi you were like yeah man common
sense let's do this
um so unpack how the heck you got to a
destination
before everyone else and one of the
things i like to do on the podcast is
talk about people's paths or arcs or
origin stories
and you have an origin story that is
essentially
impossible slash unthinkable
[Laughter]
really i mean
and and these kinds of experiences tend
to bring out either the best or worst in
people
uh and in your case it's very much the
former you're one of the most positive
can-do-spirited people that i know
but i remember when i i first put two
and two together as to the fact that i'd
seen a fictionalized version of you on
my tv screen
and then i'd met you and then i again it
took me a little while and i was like oh
[ __ ]
like like xander is from the famous
schultz family which were champion
wrestlers and olympians yeah yeah uh so
how did you grow up and and where was
that because you have an incredible
story that most people again
wouldn't imagine is even possible sure
sure yeah i mean
my life's gone in like really
interesting chapters i think all of it
leads to this idea of you know
supporting basic income and these type
of things um started out you know the
son of dave schultz who's one of the
greatest wrestlers of all time
and basically grew up on a commune uh
that was this rich guy's property called
fox catcher and so if you haven't seen
this movie it's starring mark ruffalo
and channing tatum
but that movie is about where xander
grew up right right essentially although
that movie the hard part about that
movie i thought they did a tremendous
job those guys did a tremendous job mark
plays my dad and channing plays my uncle
in that movie um but the hard part was
it had this like dark undertone you know
and it was actually like the happiest
place on earth growing up it was
essentially a commune of people chasing
their dreams right it was like an
olympic training center where all these
guys were trying to make the olympic
team and swimming and wrestling and um
and then they all had kids who became my
like sisters and brothers and cousins
i'm very confusing when i talk to people
about like who other people are in my
life because i grew up with so many
wonderful people
um yeah and and because my dad was an
olympic champion wrestler we also had um
all the other olympic teams come stay at
our house my dad was known as this great
strategist and so like other
countries teams would come live with us
for like a month at a time you know do
camps for like couple weeks and the best
wrestlers in the world
are often coming from our political foes
so the soviet union at the time is and
still russia still is the best wrestlers
in the world
uh often times in the top two or three
is iran oftentimes in the top three or
fours cuba
um north korea believe it or not has
really good lightweight wrestlers
japan has really good wrestlers um
and so i grew up on kind of this like
it's a small world disney ride
which you know i didn't even have any
preconceived notions about how people
are different so there's nothing to like
deconstruct i just started from this
default of really loving people and
seeing their differences as like
interesting but i didn't even like
they're so minor compared to all of our
commonalities right it's like the
japanese guys would come do tai chi and
i do cheat with them right the russian
guys would come over and play some chess
and teach me chess and it was like small
differences but like you know same thing
for everyone people love community
people love chasing their dreams et
cetera uh and so that was like this
really beautiful
foundation that got to kick-start my
life and on top of it the people around
me were doing big things so like i was
just talking to someone last night
about
how lucky i am that like i grew up with
so many people around me being olympic
champions and like of course you do big
things when you get older and you see so
many people have this imposter syndrome
as they step up into these different
levels of success i imagine like running
a popular presidential campaign kind of
feels like that time so you're like whoa
this is really happening you know i'm
one of like seven people in the country
that people really are putting a lot of
energy behind
um
and like because of the success i was
surrounded by i always believed that you
know it was like destiny to impact the
world and do big things in the world
well you have an elevated belief in
human potential and human capacity
the reason why the movie
presented it as so dark is because there
was this incredible tragedy yeah where
the
benefactor behind fox catcher
uh was insane
and
uh killed your father
yeah john dupont used the heir of the
dupont you know you know the dupont
chemical company dupont fortune um
basically lost his mind you know he was
already i would say like borderline very
mentally sick the whole time we were
there but um
it's kind of like the slide you saw
michael jackson on where he was like too
rich and powerful for anyone to really
like kind of stop him if he did he fired
you you know that type of thing
um and so i do that the people around me
anytime someone anyone tries to tries to
slow down my make sense yeah i'm like
look i'm descending here you're fired
yeah yeah i mean i shouldn't joke about
this because it's a thing so yeah no
it's totally fine i um
[Music]
yeah and so so basically it was a mix of
drug use mental illness
financial independence in like such a
wild way that like the guy could get
away with whatever you know he was
paying off the police department to do
stuff etc
and it culminated in him killing my
father when i was nine in 1996.
um
it became a really big news story at the
time he went holed up at his mansion
which was like a replica of monticello
you had like you know swat teams outside
this replica of monticello for three
days so it became this like massive
massive event um and then it also like
you know i'm involved a little bit in
refugee work and like this is a very
like light version
of this but also because he owned the
property that we're all living on it
obliterated that community i was telling
you about in like a day you know we were
all off it it was an olympic year too so
the other wrestlers couldn't
hang around you know they need to get
back to work pretty soon too so like
someone to the olympic training center
you know we moved to california right
after that and so there was like this
obliteration of community which was um
in the midst of this tragedy which kind
of compounded it in a lot of ways
um
yeah yeah so that's that was like the
closure
of that chapter
what what did you understand as a
nine-year-old
when this was happening
yeah
yeah it's hard to know like what you've
kind of like
deduced like since then you know versus
like what you're feeling at the time
i remember um
i feel very grateful that i knew john in
that like he was a family friend
and so i couldn't i think there's a lot
of times people come out of these
tragedies and the mythology of like a
bad guy is able to run rampant and they
want to stop the bad guys and everything
but i knew john i saw his descent first
hand so i'm getting sicker so i'm
getting more confused and in a lot of
ways i think my dad got was killed
because he like he let john knew he saw
him too he's like hey we can go to rehab
you know we'll call it my training camp
we'll go i think that was a lot of where
like this this
distrust and how he kind of built my dad
up as this monster eventually you know
his head is as he was seen by him
um but i'm really grateful for
knowing him because he was at my
birthday bars and stuff so he never was
a monster to me he was a sick guy that
sometimes did sick things like he drove
his lincoln town car into the pond you
know he burned down his greenhouse this
was all in the last hike it wasn't
always like this it was like this
descent the last couple months
um
but so it seemed like something that
happened because a sickness wasn't
addressed because there was a lack of
love when he was young and you saw it
like how the dupont family was with each
other
um and so i i think i was
lucky to be able to correctly attribute
the factors to like this outcome
uh instead of just believing that
you know there's these evil people out
there that just want to hurt people
[Music]
this is a tough time for all of us now
uh and people need someone to talk to
but the fact is your friends don't want
to hear you [ __ ] and complain about
what's going on unless you're better
friends than i do you know it's like
that that's not really what friends are
for
i think that's what friends are for in
the movies but in real life
you know who can help you out with this
betterhelp.com
they're sponsoring the podcast i am so
proud to refer people to them because
you can get
a licensed therapist on call i think of
it as like uber for therapists or mental
health on demand you can bug them
whenever you want and they will make you
feel better that's why it's called
better help you know what i mean it
actually is exactly what it says it's
going to be
i have friends and colleagues who swear
by better help i swear by better help
don't just suffer in silence get
yourself some help get some better help
today as a listener you'll get ten
percent off your first month by visiting
our sponsor betterhelp.com yang join
over one million people who have taken
charge of their mental health again
that's betterhelphep.com
yang
[Music]
so your family immediately moved out
west yeah did you have siblings sister a
sister is she older younger
younger three years younger wow yeah
so you're nine and six you move out west
with your
mom
uh and
what did she do for a living like what
was that
so we had on the heels of this we have
this criminal trial
which was you know this this massive
media event and then we had a civil
trial
and so on the civil trial we had the
settlement
and which is like
getting us closer to the answer around
basic income and everything too and so
the settlement was enough where my mom
was
okay and able to take care of us
um and then we had something waiting for
us when we turned 18 as well um so it
was nice in that like
this is what's so wild like i see how
damaging that
that um event was for me
right i ended up dropping out of high
school went to like five high schools
dropped out really struggled um didn't
think i was struggling in time but
clearly
and
we were so well supported
like there's so many people in our
country that go through things like this
um that have none of that right we had
financial support we had literally my
dad was one of the most popular
wrestlers in the world and not just like
because he was a great athlete people
really loved him so there were so many
people like the community that
surrounded us and just made sure i was
good no matter how much of an [ __ ] i
was i was like a teenager they just kept
coming back and supporting me like that
community level especially in the united
states we're so [ __ ] lonely here
especially united states we don't have
it and then the financial
wherewithal that we had that my mom
could you know support me through those
processes higher counseling whatever and
like also i could just continually
fail
for you know up until i'm like 21 22 and
be okay right and pick myself back up
um
just folks don't have that and we had
that and we're like it's so incredibly
lucky
did you feel immense pressure as the son
of a world class athlete yeah yeah
yeah yeah definitely because wrestlers
are the toughest dudes there are yeah
i wrestled very poorly for one year
i did as well
uh so i have a lot of respect and
admiration uh for the people who excel
at it because it requires such
discipline wild amounts of discipline
and and fortitude and toughness
um so i can only imagine what it would
be like having
a father who's literally a world
champion yeah yeah yeah i went to it's
funny i went to um i played basketball
growing up which is like i think
partially reaction what you're talking
about i was like
the ceiling for like a five foot 10
white guy is so low in basketball people
are just proud of me if i make my high
school team or whatever but i went to
joint came about 16
and i roomed upstairs downstairs was
jeffrey jordan michael's son he was
playing basketball i'm like i can't
believe
you're playing basketball man like
you're like
yeah we'll trade man like you let me
practice with your dad i'll get you a
bunch of coaches like this is insane he
had such a great attitude about it i i
definitely didn't i don't know if it was
because my dad went from like a really
good wrestler to like a martyr and then
also someone who wasn't present for me
so it's not like i had
like the coaching of an olympian i just
had like the branding right
and so
uh so i that one year i got smashed
because kids were very excited
excited to smash me
and you know that's that's about enough
of that you know you don't need a lot of
those experiences before you're like
maybe i'll switch this up it doesn't
hurt so bad when i miss layups it'll be
all right
but yeah i really felt that and i think
even like
that still translates to today like when
i said i'm really appreciative of like
this
this like license to want to achieve big
things there's also like the pressure to
achieve big things which i still think
is like i've you know deconstructed some
of this and got to a healthier place
with this i'm not like
you know only motivated by you know
uh
the wrong type of energy but i i think
that continues to be a thing you know my
dad was known for bringing people
together and being a bridge builder he
was an american that would hang out in
the soviet union or in iran you know in
tehran for for long periods of time and
spoke their languages and like build
bridges you know he's called the
wrestlers wrestling's greatest
ambassador and so i think
that's kind of the thread of that
pressure that i've
chosen to follow
um but it was certainly there it's
certainly still there to an extent for
sure well you do bring people together
like very few other people i know
uh and you're obviously right that
most americans don't have the ability to
stumble and fall and stumble and fall
and and get back up
um you have one of the most powerful
mindsets of both empathy and abundance
i've ever encountered really and you
recently texted me something around look
this is the first time in human history
where we actually have ample resources
to provide for everyone yeah yeah but
this window will not remain open forever
totally because and the two dangers you
posed were climate change and the rise
of authoritarianism yeah both of which
you're right about obviously i mean we
we can see uh both of them
and
your message to me and what's funny is
i'm like the presidential candidate of
universal basic income uh your message
to me actually was like a reminder to me
which was
um you know which is again one reason
why
um
uh why i love spending time with you so
much so when you are 21 you start
hitting your stride and you have this
pressure to achieve big things
uh
how did you end up
um
channeling your energies yeah
well just real quickly to touch on what
you just said like i think that's like
what's hard when you get dragged into
like the tactics and the strategy stuff
is like
you kind of i start putting like my
10-year goal on top of my to-do list
just like remember yes yeah you're like
oh yeah that's the thing that's a very
good lesson and like okay everything
filters down from that like the ten year
of the one year and then like get into
sure you're like gantt chart and you're
like task for the day and all that stuff
but it's hard it's why i love you know
chatting with you as well like you do
the same thing for me right it's like
once you i've become more
tactical as i've become an operator in
some of these things and it's hard to
like keep in mind it's like bigger thing
that we're spreading towards sometimes
um
but right around 21 what was the
question again sorry i just how did you
end up channeling your energies when and
and what's interesting is i think you
and i might share this
where there was a point
where my my parents said to me look if
someone else can do it you should be
able to do it too yeah you have
you know the capacities and what they
were describing at the time was just
getting good grades
um but
uh i got
that
bug early on and i saw other people
starting companies so i said oh i should
be able to start one too totally and my
first company failed and so that hurt
but then i worked with more experienced
entrepreneurs and tried again and then i
had some success try it again and the
rest of it so i can certainly relate to
the entire stumbling and having the
license to
both fail and then get up and recover
that's how you learn
uh so what was your development process
like after you decided to try and start
building things in your 20s totally well
like my my experience which was um it
was even less about like the goals at
the moment i had uh interned with with
my godfather scott gregolinski that was
also a really successful wrestler that
was successful in wall street
and he he kind of was like look you're
you're being ridiculous like just come
under my wing for like three months help
me with you know help me with my work
and everything and um
i learned about habits like i was
hanging out with him and he's like hey
every day we wake up at five we then we
work out and we write down the three
things we need to do today for it to be
a successful day and then we clear our
inbox you know by like seven we eat a
healthy breakfast you know we go into
the office an hour early you know we we
start knocking out those three things
it's like 9 30 and we've already done
everything we need to do to have a
successful day
and i was like so i did this for three
months and like i was really doing it i
had no discipline before you know and i
was like
no one teaches you this no one teaches
you like habits like how to set goals
and habits and like we just download
people with information i remember
missing like i had a 0.0 gpa one
semester in high school i went missing
tests i'm like how how does everyone
even know there's a test this day like
no one was around you know single parent
household my uncle raised me
sometimes he came in to help because my
mom was gone a lot with the trials and
these things uh my uncle passed away as
well i had aids and then overdosed and
and so like there was just like i was
kind of on my own in a lot of ways like
even though i had so much communal
support on the day-to-day level and just
like being able to see a successful guy
do these things um
and i was like well this is i don't know
if i can be as successful as this guy
but i can have this morning like i know
i can have this morning after doing this
to emulate the behavior yeah exactly
like i can emulate this behavior and so
i was like okay i'm gonna go i'm gonna
go back to school then like that's that
was the first day i'm just gonna like
try to
apply this and i went back to school and
i got a 4.0 the first semester i was
like huh
interesting like that i will say that if
you woke up at 5am and banged [ __ ] out
yeah uh you would probably
do better than the average college
student
like mind you too like i'm not trying to
paint myself as a hero mind you i had
financial stability at this point and
like you know i was 21 i wasn't 18. and
so and i just had this experience
um
and and so anyway so that happened so i
was like wow that was great i'm gonna
i'm gonna go back to school and i'm
gonna i'm gonna volunteer full-time and
i'm gonna do a semester i volunteered at
this place called reading partners i was
helping like underprivileged kids get up
to speed and i got another 4-0 i was
like holy [ __ ] this is like
it's like in i felt like you know in
street fighter when you're choosing a
character and they've got like different
attributes i'm like this is like the
screen i can be whoever i want to be if
this is all it takes is like investing
in these habits and like just picking
which ones you want to be good at
and um and then so from there i got
involved in a startup called kefi um
started as an intern i'm like do
whatever but i was on the founding team
over there and then became a project
manager over there that sold to google
and like you're starting to like look at
this resume of yours build up like i'm
an honorable student been like founding
team at like a startup that's sold to
google and you're like doesn't even feel
because i was still so close to the
failing version of myself time wise i
hadn't evolved that much as a human you
know other than applying this stuff
and um
and so i think between
between learning the power of habits and
um and then also the
financial freedom to kind of take big
swings like we always talk about
entrepreneurs like taking risks and i
was like this
most people don't have the
capacity to take those risks because if
they fail their song it's over you know
and for me it was the opposite of risky
what am i going to do i'm going to be an
entry sales level person or i'll like
try to start some [ __ ] up and like if it
fails but at least i ran a startup it's
like an infinitely better experience you
build a better network et cetera so it
was the opposite
of risky for me too but i think those
two things were like started to be
really influential in what i wanted for
everyone because i felt and i had been
less than normal like failing right i
was like man i felt like almost the
opposite of what you said with your
parents like if they can do it you can
do it if i can do it
and we give this formula to like
humanity
i don't know what's going to come of it
you know i i
we've never had that world
and i think that's what really excites
me about basic income i think we're
using one percent
of humans maybe less than one percent of
humans to like drive us forward and we
think of society as like we're still in
this mode where it's like everyone's
gotta work like that's the purpose of
like everyone's gotta work and i think i
i talked to my friend nick fitz who
um runs a company called momentum the
other day and he had this really
beautiful metaphors like we need to
think of society like a vc it's like
we're going to cut
you know 300 million checks in america
and hopefully
you know it's a success if 10 of those
folks become i don't know how you feel
about elon musk but like elon musk esque
in terms of driving humanity forward in
some capacity right um you could pick
and choose a different person
i like elon and
uh i completely understand what you'd
think of as like the power law
distribution it's like look i don't need
200 million of these to work out yeah
yeah
why are we so afraid of 200 million
people smoking weed and chilling and
like
50 that like make us sustainable and you
know eliminate desperation and
and all right now that wouldn't be the
preferred distribution of course you'd
like to think lots of people would be
you know somewhere in the middle
and i guess like
also i'd add to that i came into money
at a time where i was smoking weed
hooking up with girls not doing much and
that financial freedom
was the flip side of like the argument
you always hear you're like everyone's
gonna hang out and smoke weed and i was
like my life was so
intense and depressing i was like
numbing myself you know to these like
you know different traumas and stuff we
had been through
and like the fact that all of a sudden i
felt like everything was feasible all of
a sudden i could take in so much
information like the privilege of having
wealth wasn't just like the money the
money's great it was everything became
realistic i'm like i'm gonna learn about
real estate because maybe i'll invest in
a house soon you know and so it was all
applicable you could take it on
[Music]
welcome to fallen angel a documentary
podcast about victoria's secret and its
many many secrets
our new series investigates the origin
story and meteoric rise of one of the
world's most iconic brands the legendary
business mogul who created the
inescapable fantasy and the reckoning
that victoria's secret faces today all
told by women who strutted the runways
and witnessed what happened behind the
curtain
i was so hungry and my body wasn't
working he said that women only work out
to look good naked to have sex with men
like just gross a direction and
production of c13 originals a cadence 13
studio and campsite media and hosted by
vanessa gregoriotis and me justine
harmon
fallen angel is available to listen to
for free wherever you listen to your
podcasts like you might have made a deal
with the devil
and they called it angels because now
you are locked in
[Music]
well one of the things i said on the
campaign trail all the time was that it
is impossible to train someone in
financial literacy if they don't have
money yeah because it's all [ __ ] and
imaginary totally you know and if you
actually do have money and i
had an experience that was not unlike
this where i studied economics in
college
and understood all the principles yeah
but it still didn't matter until you
actually had right a couple bucks to rub
together totally like oh okay now i
guess i'm gonna have to figure out what
i'm gonna do with this totally uh and
so
i think we should be teaching people
financial literacy and then giving them
all money uh senior year in high school
i mean i proposed obviously the freedom
dividend of a thousand bucks a month
starting at age 18 it would
and i also agree with you in the
activation where when you get this money
you're like oh it's real okay i guess i
got to figure [ __ ] out yeah yeah yeah
got it like i think one of the things i
i
i thought was going to naturally occur
uh if the freedom dividend became a
thing is people start living together
and you're like okay well there's now
four of us with 48k you can go back to
school you can you know you can work
particularly people would pool resources
there'd be really cool stuff happening
that like people couldn't like i think
totally see when they just thought about
like a person getting 12 000 bucks
you're like no no like and also the
communities that most need that already
do this to an extent yeah like they'd be
able to apply in ways that like you know
so effectively that people like myself
who has always been comfortable i can't
even imagine you know yeah the child tax
credit i love it it's lifting
tens of millions of people and families
out of poverty
but i do think it would be great if
people who didn't have kids also got
that money you know what i mean
because in a lot of ways like those
people have to pragmatically spend that
it's like i got a mouth to feed and it's
not so much money it's not like these
people are like balling out that yeah
it's 50 bucks a month per kid right
but
i think a lot in a lot of ways your
basic income proposal freedom dividend
was aptly named and that like a lot of
times like the freedom that would create
for a lot of people who maybe didn't
have to immediately spend it on feeding
that mouth would create so much
value and like not for nothing like
happiness and purpose in people's lives
and all those things that like i think
are hard to see sometimes in the way our
society is constructed it's hard to see
like how
people talk often about um how americans
aren't really in poverty right it's like
we'll compare them to you know people in
liberia they're not in poverty but i
think the threat americans face if they
are impoverished is so intense right
it's not like to go back to the
community thing right you don't have a
lot of people to lean on you're kind of
on your own we don't have really a
social safety net at all
so you can fall so far so and usually in
debt like you only have like a month you
know to not have that play out and
you're just trying to make it ends meet
all the time
so much of our society is in that mind
frame and i don't think we properly
attribute
um that reality to some of the outcomes
that we're seeing completely
i think
if you falter in america today it's very
isolating there's a lot of shame
associated with it
and
you don't have that lattice or web of
connections that are going to protect
you or
put you back on your feet one of the
facts that i found striking
is that unemployed men
volunteer less and attend religious
services less than employed men right
which you think for a second is like
wait a minute you have more time so you
could clearly do those things
but when you lose that
sense of connection and purpose you
actually withdraw
and check out what we're seeing over and
over again in american life
uh and
putting resources into people's hands i
think would like you said give everyone
um a reason to be able to come together
and and try and pursue things
collectively because
there's like such a loss of
value now in american life if things go
poorly
uh and uh it's it's it's heartbreaking
really when i think about so many people
whose
um potential is is being lost as a
result yeah i'll say like i spent the
last 18 months
basically living on the road because we
were on the 4th first floor of this
building out here in battery park city
there's like 10 people in the elevator
right when the pandemic kicked off we're
like this is this is not the scene you
know you want to be in we were lucky
enough to have family that could take us
in so we've been in all these different
places staying with family you know san
diego and lake tahoe and portland with
myself and my wife's family
and
it's interesting because i feel like new
york
ruined my uh
my ability to interact with people
socially because so many people are
dealing with that reality outside of
this little bubble so many people are
dealing with reality that you're talking
about where they don't want to
talk about what's going on with them you
know you come up to anyone new york
you're like tell me about your mission
man what's going on how can i help you
and you know you'll fight right back at
me like i'm trying to fix democracy and
get every money let's do this and you
get out there and they almost feel
attacked you know ask him you know hey
what's going on man what's your name
what's your goals this year you know hey
like let's talk about football
see this and yeah you're totally right
like people when they're not in a
healthy state like they recede
from their communities because like they
don't want to answer that question
there's a real punitiveness and i'm
going to speak uh speak to it for men in
particular maybe just that i can relate
to and also i think societally it's
something that we're dealing with uh
which is that as a guy it's very very
tough
to evince struggle
uh or share vulnerability yeah
particularly if there are
uh financial strains involved it's like
as a dude it's like you know yeah yeah
you do not want to
seem like you're hard luck
um
and i remember this with my you know i
mean obviously in very different
circumstances but um when my first
company failed like i felt like such a
failure to my core totally and you know
in my case obviously everything was
going to be fine but you know
like but it doesn't feel that way yeah
and so then if you actually are someone
who the who's
hitting tough times and the exigencies
are real like you might not be able to
make ends meet um it's very especially
in just society we're like we so bought
in on it being a meritocracy totally
like we just don't believe in systemic
factors in the same way or even just the
ebbs and flows of a life right like
we're all on trajectory in this
trajectory and it should be pointing
this way all the time
um totally if company failing is like
brutal for that
for that reason i've also had a failed
campaign or two
but but uh you know it's
to be fair i wouldn't count your
presidential campaign as a failed
campaign i consider that an advocacy
campaign around basic income and any
poverty that i'm sure you wanted to
then result in a presidential i i was
very very happy yeah with the outcome
yeah um i thought it was so important i
think it's one of the most important
campaigns that's been run in this
country in a long time for that reason
thank you xander i feel the same way i'm
super grateful to everyone who helped
make it happen you among them and i have
to say of the people i encountered
during this time you were one of the
earliest
and then the most
pure about it like there was zero
uh
maintenance necessary so anytime you
thought you could land a hand and you
just make it happen without having to
frankly like bug me or bug anywhere
it's like try and make it happen yeah
which is a joy uh it's something that um
you relish
when you're the candidate where you're
like oh xander's just making good [ __ ]
happen right and uh you know like
doesn't need like copious thank yous for
the rest of that justice dude that goes
back to like that mission statement
sitting on the top of my inbox like
there's eradicate desperation you think
i'm gonna be able to do that myself like
i'm so excited when someone
you know comes into my orbit or i force
my way into their orbit as i did with
you
and and they can start driving that
forward you know in some ways that's so
exciting to me and so like if i can be
i'm not gonna solve all these things
myself and very few times will i be the
proper person to be the face of any of
these solutions um and so
you know i'm just i'm just like anytime
i meet someone like that that's driving
that hard towards something like that
um i'm just excited to be a participant
and try to move the needle i think like
your presidential
debate too like not for nothing like
basically income things important but i
also think at a point in time
we were being increasingly convinced
that there was a segment of our
population that was evil
you were pointing out that this is
actually like the expected outcome of
these circumstances between automation
and globalization and you're like you
know pointing out how many people are on
disability how much people are
struggling and how much that population
wasn't being spoken to
like i think you brought
dude because it was a really difficult
time for a lot of people like you were
really believing you know family members
were evil and you it was so wild that
you could believe that
people could hear someone like trump and
then support him over
you know an elizabeth warren or
something that is so like nice and
reasonable and just fun bernie sanders
just wants poor people to be less poor
and
and i think um
it was a tough space to sit in like i'm
not someone who likes to sit in like a
feeling of hate or anger ever oh yeah
you're one of the most positive generous
souls i know yeah
which uh which
plays into your work with refugees and
you send me pictures of you and refugee
camps periodically yeah and uh it's
amazing how did you get involved and
tell us a little bit about the work yeah
i mean you know company failure thing is
like the genesis of that so our
i had a startup called complete that was
like a
uh it was like the most positive place
on the internet i still wish it existed
it was a social network where people
shared their tasks and goals it was all
future facing and then people would
comment be able to help you you know and
then you would check it off so like kind
of was a to-do list and a wow it's like
an affirmation i get it yeah yeah
it was affirmations information it was
collaboration it was like my my
most amazing conversation is often about
like what you're trying to do right and
i've had so much of my successes in life
be because of the serendipity of just
like announcing what i hoped to have
happened one day and then people helping
me along the way
um so we turned that into a social
network which was like beautiful people
quit smoking and ran marathons and cool
stuff but so affirming i love the sound
of this yeah but there's no nudes on the
website
and like you know kendall jenner's
posting
hot picks so we didn't we didn't take
off like some of the other ones in the
same way but you know we had a good run
and then that went under i was feeling
bummed and like actually like my first
way to try to solve this was totally the
opposite you know i went to italy and
like tried to like eat my way out of it
with my wife and like you know drink a
bunch of espressos and and hang out out
there which was nice but like didn't
solve this kind of hole that was in me
and then uh we went to crete where my
wife's family's from and we started
looking for wedding venues this was fall
2015
and you know really came into contact
with the european refugee crisis like it
was the the story of the moment it was
omnipresent
and uh
it just started feeling silly at a
certain point and we were like looking
for a wedding venue and you know eating
this good food and everything all this
stuff was happening so close
and so my wife and i just decided to go
over there for like a month and
you know see what we could do um we
don't have any like medical skills or
anything like that we're just like let's
just get over there and see see what can
happen that was that was the beginning
of you know being on this island of
lesvos that's considered like the
gateway
to europe and us starting our our work
over there
so you guys got uh supplies and
yeah i mean we brought some supplies but
like
i was really just kind of implementing
some of my startup bro skills like i got
the whole island on slack and there were
like different channels it was very
organized yeah yeah i was like well they
were you know it's it's wonderful people
but a lot of times it was like you know
hippies that like hadn't been in
management at all and you know they're
doing their best but they're like a
single whatsapp group for like
everything happening we were taking in 4
000 people a day so i like applied some
of that and create a splash page where
people could come like you know enter
what skills they had and so people could
you know know where to where to place
them a scheduling you know system they
organize the refugee camp
yeah or the volunteers at least you know
um
it was a wild time like you'd think
you're like it'd be a bunch of feel good
stuff but a lot of times
i'd never i'd never volunteered in a
place where like we were resource scares
and so a lot of the time what you're
doing is like resource guarding like you
weren't like giving everyone a jacket
you were protecting the five jackets
that you had and trying to judge who was
going to die of hypothermia oh okay so
you're telling people who are coal you
know it wasn't it wasn't intense it was
a super intense experience
um
but you know also
formative and kind of my world view of
who we are in the world and you know
what we're up to and what
who we say we are versus you know what
we're doing
um
so so intimate and human man i mean most
people don't spend months in refugee
camps yeah um trying to trying to help
people stay warm
[Music]
let's say you wake up in the morning and
you need a kick you're the type of
person who wants a cup of coffee but not
just any cup of coffee you're kind of a
coffee nerd a coffee aficionado coffee
snob even you also like things that are
personalized to you where you want to be
able to express your preferences you
would imagine
getting coffee from 55 plus small u.s
based roasters who are committed to
ethical and sustainable
sourcing you can give feedback
if this all sounds like you in a cup
then trade is what you've been looking
for trade will send you personalized
coffees
that you've identified and for our
listeners right now trade is offering
your first bag free and five dollars off
your bundle at checkout
this is what you've been waiting for to
get yours go to drinktrade.com
yang and use promo code yang take the
quiz to start your journey to the
perfect cup of coffee to start the day
right that's drinktrade.com yang promo
code yang for your first bag free and
five dollars off your bundle let's go
trade
so the work you're doing right now is
something i believe very very strongly
in and i want to try and set the stage a
number of articles have come out
recently that are saying that we're
still facing a crisis in our democracy
upcoming where millions of americans
still
dispute who won this last election right
we could easily
see
a republican-controlled congress
circa 2022-2024
and so there are a couple of outcomes
that have people very very concerned i
think that
donald trump will probably be the
republican nominee there's a chance he
just wins straight up because
right now you'd have to say it's some
somewhat neck and neck yeah i mean
obviously a lot of things for change i
mean who the heck knows
but then there's this other scenario
that
various journalists have laid out saying
that
uh if it's a disputed election a
republican-controlled congress could
just certify the results republican
secretaries of state uh in certain
states could just certify results
secretary states are dangerous right now
man in this moment there's at least one
state i think arizona that said that now
a majority vote of the state legislature
can certify the results
uh and so we're heading
towards
crisis territory for democracy
over the next
one to three years
and as someone who has been
trying to in some ways raise attention
to
institutional failures i think this
stuff is very very real uh and that we
should be
super concerned about it uh i take it
you have a similar perspective 100
percent i
our democracy is so um
it's not fair to call it stable but i
think we don't fully appreciate the
importance of it it's where all the
change sits on top of when people talk
about like you know advancing
you know climate climate response to
climate crisis or advancing you know
criminal justice reform et cetera like
we need that
that foundation of a functioning
democracy to do any of that work
um
and
i think some people are kind of
depressed about the situation but it's
it's happening because we're winning
it's happening because we're organizing
and winning effectively and actually in
a lot of ways becoming a better
democracy and this is a reaction to them
knowing this tidal wave is coming we
want georgia we flip to arizona texas is
on the brink like really like we're
winning hearts and minds and
demographics are shifting and so this is
the response like we gotta change change
the rules of the game they've been
changing the world to the game to be to
be honest you know 1.2 million 1.5
million
former felons couldn't vote in florida
you know and until we pass amendment 4
in 2018 they've been they've always
changed the rules they've always tried
to disenfranchise especially black and
brown voters um poor voters more broadly
and uh
and yeah i think this is the fight of
of this moment and like the stakes can
be higher in both directions sometimes
we talk about the other directions like
authoritarianism
um and that's fair like that moves
people oftentimes to action that hey
like
i'm so grateful for hong kong because we
just saw it we saw how quick it slips
away it feels like hong kong is a
thousand years away from becoming a
democracy again especially in this
moment where you can monitor your
citizens like that
um so that's very real but also like if
you look at the folks elected in the
house in 2018 2020 on the democratic
side we are more progressive we are more
diverse across the board racially gender
et cetera um
and there's like a real
there's a real foundation of organizing
work and other good work happening
across this country that could unlock
we've never had organizers funded funded
effectively throughout election cycles
so this is what you're working on right
now with give us the vote
uh which and our mutual friends are
working on yeah give us about give us
the ballot yeah and i love it uh
obviously
i do want to break down a couple of
things um because you and i are focused
on different aspects of this problem
yeah and so you're framing it as hey
more and more
diverse voters are getting activated we
need to register them and if we do
then democrats will prevail in more
places where they have not prevailed
heretofore and oh by the way republicans
are noticing this and then they're
passing various about restriction laws
and voter access laws that are going to
make it harder
and so
give at give us the ballot we're trying
to counter that by
investing in organizations that will
sign up voters protect ballot access
and do the work on the ground often in
communities of color yeah around the
country and this is something that i
love i i love trying to make it so that
people can actually uh vote effectively
yeah and i think it's not only do you
love like you don't i don't think it's
you've done so many things last year so
you haven't integrated this into your
story but you were fundamental
fundamental in me starting one for
democracy in defeat by tweet getting off
the ground in wimbo seats you know you
were essentially like the co-founder you
know me and you were like got that going
um sophia bush really linked in some of
these other people leaned in but really
i think you were the driving force
behind a lot of small dollar donors that
came into that so it's not just like oh
yeah i support and everything like
between all those
all those initiatives that really like
we helped start together in a lot of
ways like that moved more than 100
million dollars to organizing work you
know between all of them so so you're
effective in that fight too i want you
to i want you to like feel that you're
not just in support like a lot of those
things don't happen without your energy
at least the same level well you reached
out to me and i said this seems like a
home run uh i'm very very happy to do
what i can
um showed up at a dinner made some
tweets but it's like you know giving
your profile on everything and like what
that the trust you've built in a lot of
ways it meant a lot to all those
initiatives i i did uh do what i could
and uh you know i i appreciated the
opportunity really being a part of it
uh and i'm
a staunch supporter
because hey you know more people voting
like that that's a pure good
i'm right now and i just wrote a book on
this
is that i'm convinced that we're we're
having these structural that's my one
direct to camera
so dude he's holding just right the book
uh forward notes on the future of our
democracy pick it up you haven't picked
it up already let's get that plugging so
problem number one
uh you're having this clash over uh
ballot access and whether people are
able to vote and who can vote and you
know unfortunately at this point in our
country's history just look at certain
communities and be like oh let's keep
them from voting because they're gonna
vote for for the other side it's not
uh it's not what you want at all
um
and then there's this other suite of
problems
that you also recognize yeah yeah uh
that we're being set up in this
polarized environment where right 80 of
seats are going to be safely democratic
or or republican in the general they've
been gerrymandered to high heaven so
they are safe on on one side of the
other
and that we have to
uh
reform our voting
system so that more people have
different points of view expressed uh
and i'm championing open primaries and
ranked choice voting yeah yeah which
hopefully and and this is one of the
things i'm trying to convey to people
that i think some people are catching on
to is that if you wanted to build
a robust anti-fragile system
you wouldn't have
this two-party system that allows if for
example one of them gets overtaken by
terrible leadership then there's no
safeguard against that because the way
our country is set up did not account
for
national parties in the way they
presently exist and so if you were to
have parties you would certainly want
more than two
because then if if one right has
problems that you're like well you know
we have eight parties like sweden so you
know if one of them goes bad like you
know you just
try and uh you know let them sort it out
for
for a while um so there's this suite of
of structural issues that i'm uh now
driving at that uh i think you and i
agree on that stuff totally totally like
if you wanted to set up
a country so there would be like heavy
distrusting institutions you would set
up the way much of our systems are
structured right you'd have two parties
you'd have people run every two years so
you're constantly you know or some some
types of elections happen every two
years where you're constantly told
you're being lied to and [ __ ] over by
whoever's in there right now
um in these large you know these long
campaigns you'd have a system where you
could only choose one person and so if a
bunch of people agree and you generally
like them they kind of drown out each
other and the one dude who it's like all
new ideas whether that's for good or bad
you know rises above them and like and
you're incentivized to behave like that
so whether or not they have ideas like
that they're incentivized to tell you
the majority like basically you're
incentivized to say
the uh
the majority of things we agree on your
smart people agree on all suck
they actually all suck and these people
don't care about you it's actually over
here with this suite of ideas which of
course can't be true it can't be true
that like reasonable smart people think
you know don't have you know don't
mostly agree on what's good for our
society
um so yes that's that's a huge huge
problem in so many ways i think um
non you call it non-private primary ring
choice voting or it's a open primary
ranked choice voting um
could go a long way there could go a
long way and at least like not incentive
i want lots of new ideas trust me like
you know i like you and bernie and like
you know the the confluence of new ideas
that are now appearing and i don't want
those people to suffer from this but i
also like don't want people to be
incentivized to like just demonize
the mainstream right this is what you're
seeing so this distrusted institutions
that's happening across the board
[Music]
we're all spending a lot of time at home
and one way to make better use of our
time is to develop new skills but since
you're probably not going to have
someone come to your house and teach you
stuff the best way to learn how to
create
and improve your abilities in an area
that you've been working on
is
skillshare.com skillshare is a sponsor
of this podcast we're very proud of i'm
actually friends with one of the
co-founders of skillshare and that dude
was very very skilled let me tell you
that whether you're just looking to get
started or you're already experienced
skillshare will take you to the next
level it's also incredibly affordable
especially when compared with all the
other stuff out there an annual
subscription is less than ten dollars a
month i know imagine getting better jedi
skills for that kind of sum you could
move things with your mind you can't do
any of those things actually but you can
get better at your vocation your job
your hobby at skillshare.com explore
your creativity at skillshare.comyang
and get a one month free trial of
premium membership that's right you can
get one month for free that's one month
of a premium membership at
skillshare.com yang our sponsor
skillshare
[Music]
so one of the compelling figures uh
in in my book let's talk about my own
book that way
um
the trust in media among democrats is 69
the trust in media among republicans is
15 so this goes back to your entire
there's the institutional layer and then
there's the complete mistrust of
institutional
uh
motivation and independents are
somewhere in the middle with 36 percent
yeah trusting media and someone said to
me something that i'm going to i'm going
to repeat uh i guess i wonder if i can
attribute it uh to her but she said at
this point you have disintegration
versus manage decline
it's the way she presented like the
right the the choice and what what's
interesting is that i'm
um
trying to
rejuvenate or resuscitate various
institutions uh i think that our current
setup is not working very well
uh
and the tough part now is if you have
faltering institutions and then people
are running around saying like hey the
institution's sucking the rest of it
you're like uh yeah you know we still
need to like fix this or make it better
and then you go to the institutions and
be like hey can you get better
like can you like do better or be better
and then a lot of institutions don't
really have that capacity
to somehow reform themselves and the
rest of it uh and so now my people on
the inside are the beneficiaries of the
way it's currently constructed too right
not to like sow more seeds of distrust
but also like the motivation to change
things radically it's hard if you
already figured it out and you're there
like you're gonna be incremental in the
changes that you want to see just by
yeah and you don't blame the humans i
mean in some cases i i really you know
and like and admire a lot of the humans
um but
you do wind up institutionalized
in various ways yeah i think this is
like a reasonable summary of
the the core problem in american life
right now is that you have
struggling institutions that aren't able
to
reform or rejuvenate themselves
meaningfully americans are getting more
and more ticked off uh and despondent or
we're like oh you know
why is it that you can only distribute
17 percent of rental aid in eight months
like you know
that doesn't seem
effective and then there's this growing
force of people that are like
institutions suck we don't believe
anything you say we don't trust you and
then uh and then folks like you and me i
think are there being like look
yeah like things aren't great but we're
gonna try and make them better as
quickly as possible like you know where
we're um it's very something you point
about basic income they suck due to
design not the people like they suck
because they're designed in a way that
that is really problematic yes um not
because like there's lots of like
nefarious people that want to ruin your
lives out there and everything we're
electing some of those types of people
because of how it's designed but for the
most part it's it's a design issue in
the same way poverty is like a
problematic design not like
trumpism is a symptom
of a few things right that we haven't
addressed including poverty yeah
yeah and and it leads us back to basic
income really i mean if you were to get
the boot off of people's throat
um give them a sense of possibility and
abundance and humanity really uh and my
my big argument
on the trail was look people can tell if
you're investing in them and people can
tell if you're bullshitting them yeah
like like one of the comparisons i said
is like you can tell after one day on
the job whether that company gives a
[ __ ] about you
and so if we genuinely invested in
people they would know that and feel
that
and i think then you'd have at least a
chance of trying to rebuild that trust
yeah yeah yeah i mean it's the opposite
of our welfare structure now right you
wait in all these lines you have to
prove how poor you are you get punished
for taking a job you know it's the
opposite like these guys don't trust me
at all they don't trust you at all don't
trust me at all and i'm just trying to
navigate this nightmare of a situation
i was just in california and it was a
state legislator who actually said that
he was convinced that we needed
something like basic income because the
programs were set up in such a punitive
uh
way intentionally yeah and so he looked
at it and said we should be moving to
base and it was very heartening that
this was a state legislator um so we are
making progress
uh are you so you are one of the most
optimistic people i know um right now i
am relatively
negative about
the way a lot of things are going yeah
um how do you feel
a little bit of both i think 2021's been
hard because i it seems like the the
public sentiment is like we elected
biden we got a democratic senate and
like the adults are back in the room and
things are
okay and unless and that's fair like
that's unless you're really close to
this stuff it feels that way right you
don't see this like underbelly
of erosion or decay
there's like a lot of bad feeling yeah
and it's like like i get the sense that
people are still
uh sad and angry out there yeah yeah
yeah fair enough i i think i'm thinking
about um
the ease in which i was able to get
folks to cut
checks to fix some of our systems during
that election year
and the uh difficulty in
getting folks to stay in the fight
and i used two words that i probably
shouldn't use i used erosion decay but
it's intention it's an attack we're
essentially in a cold civil war like it
sounds like dramatic to say that i
really think we are i think you know
when you look at how most countries
crumble it's not an external attack it's
people consolidating power kind of
breaking apart the power of the people
and you know was it john adams who said
like democracies die by suicide yeah
democracies die by suicide it's a great
quote um
if and there's there's a side
i don't know if it's suicide though in
that like
like the
current republicans who are doing a lot
of this don't see it as suicide they see
the pathway to power right and so like
it's suicide for some of us
um
but that's taking place right now and
it's a real fight and it doesn't maybe
look like a real fight because the way
you win in that fight is you inspire
people and yeah and that's the tricky
thing is that the fight's on but
a lot of people can't tell the
difference between
uh partisan conflict and
the the totally destruction of democracy
it's hard because it is democracy in and
of itself is now a partisan yes
fight yeah you know is one side that
would like and that is the problem in my
mind
and it's a problem born in part of the
fact that you have a two-party system
totally and then you go to some media
can't talk about like that because
they're supposed to be like balanced
instead of balancing on the truth
they're trying to balance balance on not
getting too partisan you know too
partisan
uh but the truth is we're in a cold war
right now really
and it took a conservative
uh to point out uh the danger this uh
op-ed by robert kagan and you know it's
funny
where he sees it more clearly because
i i think because conservatives see it
more
more clearly right right uh but this to
me is the the fight it's the fight of
our lives uh you're one of the foremost
champions and leaders
in in the fight you've helped guide me
uh and
channel my efforts over the last number
of years uh if someone wants to help you
save our bacon yeah yeah like uh where
do they go um depends who you are so if
you're someone with serious resources uh
i would love for them to go to one for
democracy and join us it's a community
of wealthy people pledging one percent
of their net worth
every year uh we're taking four year
pledges election cycle pledges to
improving our democracy now that could
look like the organizing work that i was
just talking about but could also look
like this systemic reform work that
you're leading as well um
you know it could could work like you
know combating misinformation um but
things that can help strengthen our
democracy so if you're someone with
resources
take that one percent pledge take that
one percent pledge it's one percent it's
not that like we made it intentionally
one percent like it feels silly saying
no i won't do that it makes me feel like
we just have work to do in explaining
what how important our democracy is and
how
how brutal and intense this threat is
right now when i get anyone saying no i
have taken this pledge if you've got
lots of resources head to one for a
democracy so what if they don't have
resources you don't have resources like
that that i got you taken care of as
well uh i've partnered with martin
luther king jr's son martin luther king
the third you introduced me to yeah
and his wife andrea
she's great too fantastic people world
class totally and we've launched this
campaign called give us the ballot that
you were talking about earlier we're
asking people to donate a dollar a day
to fund organizing work that's fighting
voter suppression protecting our
democracy
right now we have a three-pronged
strategy of folks fighting in some of
these more aggressive states like texas
georgia mississippi alabama
we're investing folks in west virginia
and arizona they're helping pass a
federal bill
and then there's there's folks like
black voters matter color of change pack
black male voter project and uh martin
and andreas uh drum majors for change
that are helping drive the narrative
keep people's attention you know they're
really good martin andrea just led this
awesome march for voting rights in dc
that you know
brought the news cycle back to this
issue and so those are the types of
groups that we're investing in um and
we're asking people to give a buck a day
which almost everyone can do and that's
moving 501c for work if people aren't
familiar with that
uh 501c3 work is tax deductible but not
explicitly political this is political
organizing money that can be incredibly
hard to fundraise for and so by default
we're one of the biggest funders in the
space
c4 money is more flexible and impactful
in some ways because c3 money you can
only find c3s to give it to or c4 you
can be just explicit yeah so
wherever it's most effective yeah so i
think that's very smart uh and xander
schultz does appear sometimes on social
media as a as an individual so you can
follow him too but it's one for
democracy give us the ballot uh save us
all xander schultz uh together together
zade is such a good dude i mean
obviously he really does bring
incredible people to each effort
and you'll see for yourself if you check
out uh anything he does xander such a
pleasure my friend
um
it's uplifting anytime i get to talk to
you and spend time with you love you
brother thanks for having me on and you
know looking forward to just keeping
helping you with all this stuff man
we're gonna do it we're gonna do it you
heard it here
hear it here first thanks andrew all
right thank you
[Music]
you